تم إصدار صورة جديدة لملك بريطانيا تشارلز
وكاميلا إلى جانب
الدعوة الرسمية
للتتويج القادم، والتي تشير إليها باسم الملكة
كاميلا للمرة الأولى، مما يمثل
تغييرًا عن لقب الملكة القرينة الذي
كانت تستخدمه حتى الآن،
وستتخذ خدمة الارتباط  أقيم حفل التتويج في
وستمنستر آبي في لندن يوم
6 مايو أمام 2000 ضيف،
كما أعلن قصر باكنغهام أنه
تم اختيار ثماني صفحات شرف لحضور
التتويج بما في ذلك حفيد الملك تشارلز ووريث
العرش الأمير
جورج
أم
كنت أتحدث إلى شخص ما.  القصر
هذا الصباح يقولون إن التتويج هو
الوقت المناسب لبدء استخدام الملكة
كاميلا بصفة رسمية،
قالوا إن لقب القرينة تم استخدامه
لتجنب
بعض الالتباس فيما يتعلق بالملكة
إليزابيث الثانية والآن هو
الوقت المناسب لبدء استخدام لقب الملكة، لذا
هل هو قرار
على أساس الحساسية العامة، فقط
أرادوا الانتظار لبعض الوقت بعد
وفاة الملكة إليزابيث الثانية، نعم
وأعتقد أنه في ذهن الجميع
أنك تعلم أن ديانا ستكون الملكة
ديانا، لذا فهي تدخل في  اللقب
الذي كانت ستحصل عليه وكان هناك
قدر كبير من الحساسية حول ذلك
ولكن أعتقد أن تشارلز وضع
قدمه وقال إنني أريدها أن تكون
ملكة